There's that song again. Settle in close by the water, little ones — the willow's all leafed out now, full spring. Now, I want to ask you something, and then I want to do the hardest thing an old elephant can do: I want to keep my mouth SHUT and let somebody else figure it out. The question is this. When you LOVE someone... is it kinder to hand them the answer? Or to step back, and let them reach it themselves?
Now — this happened on a warm green afternoon, the kind where the whole Creek smells like new grass. We were all just sitting, lazy and glad. And then a gentle leaf-shuffle came up the path — soft cloth, a little creak of leather — and somebody we don't see near often enough stepped in. Listen.
Mm. You kept the pond just the way I remember it. Good. A pond like this is worth coming back for.
...And well, would you look at that. Bramble's back — the wandering teller of tales from out past the borderlands, who comes and goes like the weather. The little ones lit up. And so, of course, did I — because Bramble never comes empty-handed.
And down the bank crashed Bongo the bear cub, with his usual cheerful crash, nearly into the pond. He said,
BRAMBLE! You're back! Did you bring a story? Please tell me you brought a story. I have been so READY for a story I practiced my listening face all winter.
And in zipped Zippy the hummingbird, three places at once, already mid-thought,
A story! Wait — wait — I just had SEVEN ideas about how to listen FASTER! What if I take notes? What if I take notes in the air, with my wings, super quick, and we save TIME?
And up out of the creek scrambled Rex the river otter, dripping and delighted, like he'd been waiting his whole short life for exactly this. He gasped,
A TRAVELING tale-teller, from a place none of us have ever SEEN?! Okay — okay, hold on — this is, for real, my new favorite thing. Bramble, do you do voices? You don't have to do voices. But it would be amazing if you did the voices.
I do one voice. This one. It's served me fine across a lot of country.
...That's a GREAT voice though. That's a 'sat by a hundred campfires' voice. Okay, I'll stop, I'll be quiet — I'm gonna be SO quiet you'll forget I'm even — ooh, is that your bindle? What's in the bindle?
Roads, mostly. ...You'll have to settle for the story.
Now, I'll be honest with you, little ones. The second Bramble sat down, I knew what was coming — a story with no bow on it. Bramble tells the tale, and he leaves the meaning lying right there in the grass for you to pick up yourself. And me? I love to pick things up FOR people. It is my favorite and my worst habit.
...This'll be good. ...Old Timber, sitting on his hands. ...A whole story, and he won't get to land it at the end. ...I've waited a long time to see that.
...Wise old — well. Young Shelly. Sharp as ever. ...She wasn't wrong. So. I folded my hands. And Bramble began.
Story I heard once — out toward the borderlands, where the wind doesn't have a name yet.
There was a little wild apple tree, no taller than a fawn, that grew right at the edge of a stream. And it was the most IMPATIENT tree you ever met. It wanted to be big. It wanted apples. It wanted them now.
So the first spring, it pushed and strained, and made three hard green knots it called apples. They were the size of pebbles, and bitter as rain, and they dropped off before summer. The little tree was so cross it nearly pulled its own roots up to go find better dirt somewhere else.
But it didn't. It stayed. It dug its roots down toward the stream instead of away. And it let the seasons come — green, then gold, then bare, then green again. Three whole years of them. And here's the thing nobody saw: even in the bare cold seasons, when it had no leaves at all and looked for all the world like a dead stick, it never stopped drinking from the stream right beside it. It stopped pushing. It just... drank, and waited for its turn.
And on the fourth spring, without straining at all, it was suddenly heavy and red all over with the sweetest apples in the whole valley — so many that the birds moved in, and the foxes came to nap in its shade, and not one of them ever knew it had once wanted to quit. ...That's how the tale went, anyway.
And then Bramble did the thing he always does. He stopped. And he waited. And he did not say one single word about what it MEANT. ...And oh, little ones, I had the meaning right there on the tip of my trunk.
OH. Oh, I GET it. I totally get it. The story means — never give up! The tree wanted to quit, and it DIDN'T, and that's why it won! You just push through! You stay BRAVE!
No no no — that's not it AT ALL. It's about being SMART about it. The tree wasted three whole years making bad apples! If it had just done it the clever fast way — better dirt, more sun, a little ladder of sticks — boom, apples in HALF the time. The moral is: work smarter, not slower!
Aww, but you're BOTH missing the best part! It's about FRIENDS! The birds came, and the foxes came, and everybody was so HAPPY — the moral is, if you're sweet enough, everybody comes to be near you and nobody's ever sad again! Right? Right?!
Rex, 'be sweet and everyone comes' is not a MORAL, it's a smell. That's how you describe a muffin.
Okay but be brave and push through is DEFINITELY the moral, because that's the moral of EVERYTHING. That's the moral of breakfast.
It's about being BRAVE.
It's about SPEED.
It's about HUGS.
Mm. Could be.
...He's not going to tell you. ...That's the whole point of Bramble. ...You three are going to have to think.
And here, little ones, is where I nearly RUINED everything. Because I knew. I knew all three of them had a corner of it and none of them had the whole. And my trunk came up to just... SAY it. To hand it over, tidy and finished, the way an old elephant loves to do.
But I looked at Bramble. And Bramble looked at me. And he gave the smallest shake of his head — not unkind. Just... not yet, old friend. Let them. And so I put my trunk down. And I said the hardest sentence of my whole afternoon.
...I said: 'I'm not going to tell you what it means.' ...And little ones, it COST me. My whole heart wanted to help. But helping, just then, meant being quiet — and trusting them to get there. That was the love. The stepping back WAS the love.
...Wait. You're really not gonna tell us? ...Old Timber, you're not gonna tell us EITHER? ...Both of you? At the SAME time? That's never happened in the history of grown-ups.
...Okay. ...Okay, then we gotta actually figure it out. For real. Um. ...What did the tree actually DO?
It stayed! That part I KNOW. It wanted to pull up its roots and leave for better dirt — and it didn't, it stayed right there by the stream. ...Bongo, that's your part! Not 'never quit' — just... it STAYED. It got planted.
...Yeah! It got PLANTED. It put its roots DOWN instead of running off. That's not pushing harder — that's the opposite. It's staying put even when you wanna bolt.
...Oh. Oh no. ...My part's wrong too, isn't it. It DIDN'T optimize. It stopped straining. The bad pebbly apples came when it RUSHED — and the sweet ones came when it... waited. For its SEASON.
Some things don't HAVE a fast setting. The apples came in their own time, and you can't hurry the time, you can only... be there when it's ready. That's my third. It's a season, not a stopwatch.
...So then what's MY part? I said it was about friends. But the friends came at the END. After. ...So that's not the lesson, that's the... the result.
...Rex. What did the tree drink from? ...The whole time it was waiting.
...The stream. It drank from the stream. The water right NEXT to it. ...That's why its leaves never went dry — even in the bare seasons it stayed close to the water that fed it. ...THAT'S my third. You stay close to what keeps you green.
And then — oh, this was the moment — the three of them looked at each other. Bongo holding 'planted.' Zippy holding 'in its season.' Rex holding 'close to the water.' And all at once, you could see it land. Three pieces. One whole thing.
...Stay planted. ...Wait for your season. ...And drink from the water right beside you the whole time. ...That's it. That's the whole thing. None of us had it alone.
Wait — wait — run the numbers. Bongo had one-third. I had one-third. Rex had one-third. ...That's a whole. That's exactly a whole, and NOBODY had more than a piece. ...Okay that's actually kind of beautiful and I do NOT usually say that about thirds.
And the BEST part is — we'd never have gotten it if somebody just TOLD us. We had to each bring our piece. ...Old Timber, you knew the whole time, didn't you. ...And you didn't say.
...I knew. And not telling you was the hardest gardening I have done in years. ...You don't pull a sprout up to make it grow, little ones. You water it, and you step back, and you let it reach the light its own self. That's how God grows the slow, good things. And it is how I'm learning to love you better — by going quiet, so your own voice can find it.
...Okay — okay. So the fast thing, the EFFICIENT thing, would've been to just hand us the answer. And the LOVING thing was slower. ...Huh. I really gotta build a slow setting one of these days.
Mm. ...You got there. ...I just carry the stories. Where they land is your business, not mine.
...I'll get there. I always do. ...And so, it turns out, will an apple. ...Took the tree four springs. Took Old Timber one afternoon of biting his tongue.
Now — Bramble's apple tree put me in mind of a line I love, from the Bible. It's in the very first Psalm — the book of Psalms, chapter one, verse three. King David is describing a person whose life goes well and deep and lasting. And do you know what he compares them to? Not a fast thing. Not a loud thing. A TREE.
A tree planted by the water — staying put, waiting for its season, drinking from the stream right beside it. Three things Bongo and Zippy and Rex just figured out on their own. Here's how the Bible says it:
And he shall be like a tree planted by the rivers of water, that bringeth forth his fruit in his season; his leaf also shall not wither; and whatsoever he doeth shall prosper.
Planted. In its season. By the water. The fruit comes when it comes — and the leaf stays green, because the tree never wandered off from the stream. That's the slow, good way God grows things, and us right along with them. And nobody had to be told. You just have to stay, and wait, and stay close to what keeps you green.
Until the next breeze brings us together, my friends. Grow gently out there, little ones. And when you love someone — sometimes the kindest thing is to go quiet, and let them reach it themselves.
And from his lecture branch swooped Professor Hoot, the most certain owl in Shiloh Creek. He cleared his throat — and announced,
Professor Hoot here, with a fact that is completely true. Since young Rex was dripping all over the story today — a fact about the river otter. An otter's whiskers can FEEL a fish moving in muddy water, even when its eyes can see nothing at all.
Those whiskers are so sensitive they pick up the tiny swirls a fish leaves behind in the water. There is a word for whiskers like that: vibrissae.
What does that mean? It simply means feeler-whiskers — special touch-hairs that read the water the way your fingertips read a wall in the dark.
So when the muddy water is far too cloudy to SEE through, the otter does not panic. It closes its useless eyes — and it SEES with its whiskers, by touch. A fact, true and tested. Good evening.
And there on a flat wet stone sat the Mudpuppy brothers — Splish, Splash, and Splosh — three frogs with one very important announcement. Splosh cleared his throat,
Today on Mudpuppy Minutes, we will explain... why you SNEEZE! Ah... ah... you know the one!
Simple. You sneeze because your NOSE is sitting you DOWN. A sneeze is your nose saying, that is QUITE enough out of you. Be quiet now. AH-CHOO. That means sit down.
AND ALSO — ! A bit of DUST or tickle gets up your nose, and your body goes, OUT, OUT, and shoves it back out with one big fast puff of air — AH-CHOO! That's the sneeze. ...wait. That sounded almost like a real reason.
Oh no, no — that can't be right, that's too SENSIBLE. No. You sneeze because there is a tiny mouse who lives in your nose, and when he gets bored he JUMPS on the trampoline. AH-CHOO is the trampoline going boing.
AND ALSO — that's why you close your EYES when you sneeze! So you don't see the little mouse! He's SHY! Don't look at him!
Wait — is it actually just... your nose puffing a tickle back out, like Splash said?
...nah.
Mudpuppies, mudpuppies — we have solved it. You sneeze because of the little nose-mouse on his trampoline. Boing. AH-CHOO. Don't peek.
Mm. Let me set it right before you wander off, little ones. You sneeze when a bit of dust or a tickle gets up your nose — and your body clears it out with one quick, big puff of air. Ah-CHOO. That's all a sneeze is. No mouse, no trampoline.
Splash had it, fair and square. ...Though I'll own, a shy little mouse on a trampoline is the nicer thing to picture next time your nose goes off.
See you next time... somewhere in Shiloh Creek.